Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you.
How's it going? As you can hopefully immediately tell,
especially after I just pushed that button. I uh, I forgot my book.
I didn't forget my recording equipment.
I'm having a problem with one of the chords.
I can't tell if the cord got stepped on and it's fucked up or the Jack to my
computer's messed up.
What I've learned in life to not force things because you just make a bad
situation a little worse.
So I'm just Kinda have to record this one. Uh, like this and maybe Monday,
cause I'm on the road right now. I'm out here in Nashville, Tennessee,
Nashville, Tennessee,
home with the Grand Ole Opry and that fucking river that overflows and the,
the evil look and build in downtown. Other than that, wonderful people,
great food and all that type of shit. Um,
I'm out here for one day and one day only.
I know you guys probably think, well, what the fuck bill,
you didn't advertise it on your goddamn website. Are you doing a stand up show?
I am not. What I am doing is a,
I'm doing a panel thing for F is for family with uh,
the Great Mike Price, co-creator co creator of the show from the Simpsons.
We're doing like a live thing where they show an episode and then we answered
some questions, um,
hosted by Russell Peters and it's going to be on XM Sirius.
I don't know what channel of course, cause I'm a moron,
but that's basically what I'm doing here. And then I go
off to a Calgary tomorrow morning, Calgary, Edmonton, and then Seattle.
So, oh, do I got some stories for you? I hope these levels are okay.
I did my best with them. Um, this was my plane ride out to Nashville,
so we wrote all day. And then, uh,
I took the red eye out and um,
the dude who sat next to me on the fucking plane, God bless him,
but he's one of these guys, man, if he doesn't turn it around,
he's not gonna see 50,
because he was one of those guys who was abusing his body so bad.
Like I can, like when I go go to guesses age, it's going to,
he was either like
26 to 28 or like 37.
I couldn't tell,
but he looked as old as me. Um,
he looked like he was, if he was my age, you're like, dude,
you've got like another two years.
Cause if you fucking did that to yourself for close to 48 years,
you would be done this fucking guy, man. Holy Shit. He put on a display.
All right. So you know it's late at night and take them right.
I like I said 11:00 PM and I got the aisle,
he's got the window right.
And fortunately my Sciatica is almost right. Yeah. But
gone away. And, um, I just been, you know,
taking it easy and uh,
it's just sort of naturally working itself out while doing all the,
all the stretches and all that shit. So anyways,
he's got the fucking window seat and I'm thinking I'm being smarter than the
aisle thing because all right,
if I need to stretch I can just step out into the island and won't have to step
over anybody. Um, cause I fucked up last time I went to St Louis,
I flew southwest and I wasn't thinking,
I just went to the window seat and then I was trapped, you know,
on the other side of two other people.
So this time I'm thinking I'm being smart,
but it turns out my back feels great and now all I want to do was go to sleep.
And this fucking guy, man, Holy Shit,
this guy was like crushing the fucking airport bar.
I don't know how many fucking Jack and cokes this guy drank,
but he just kept going like that. The guy would, he would just go,
can I get another one? And then the guy would bring it over and you'd be like,
my dude, thank you. Right somebody is, he said my dude,
and then he would just be sucking these sinks down.
And he was one of these fucking guys that was so out of shape.
Like he snored while he was awake. You know what I mean? He,
the noises this guy makes, right?
So after about, I don't know,
like fucking five of these things were in the flight. I'm starting to nod off,
he fucking goes to step over me.
Mountain of a man goes to step over me, you know,
which of course sorta wakes me up and he goes into the bathroom and I notice
he's wearing his socks. Fucking animal.
This guy is like trying to kill himself from all sides. You know what I mean?
Death comes from the mouth, but he's also trying to fucking speed it up.
Try to go into the express lane by bringing a little in through the fucking
pores of the bottom of his feet. People.
It's not your fault that you weren't raised right,
but you gotta look around in life. Okay. You gotta do the fucking math.
I almost think, what do you think it's is grocer to,
to be in your bare feet or in your socks?
I know initially the bare feet has worked worse,
but there's something about the socks just absorbing it and like, you know,
the next day if you put them on again after you took a shower,
you still got the fucking shit and cause it's going into your feet no matter
what. One of the grossest things. So the entire fucking flight,
this guy has just pound and Jack and cokes. I mean he had,
he must've had like nine of them on like a a,
I don't know how long that flight is, like four fucking hours.
And I'm trying to sleep and I can't get to sleep cause you know, he's a big guy,
he's a cool guy. He was trying to step over, you know, at one point I,
I did that Vietnamese gambler squat and he's like, he goes,
what are you doing? You're praying over there. You all right? And I said, no,
I gotta I gotta Sadek nervous, you know, he goes, Oh man, that's sucks.
So I couldn't get mad at him cause he was friendly,
but every time he went to step over me,
he'd fucking wake me up and then I'd look and he'd be going the bathroom just
wearing new socks. And it just was driving me fucking nuts. So finally,
all I'm thinking is going, my God,
when this fucking mountain of a man goes down,
like he is going to Snore, like, uh,
I mean I've never had the displeasure of sleeping next to Terry Saragoussi,
whatever's Tony Saragoussi,
but I imagined he was gonna sound like whatever that guy sounds like at like two
o'clock in the fucking morning. Right. But it was aware to stay.
He was snoring while he was awake, but when he was, when he went to sleep,
he didn't make a fucking sound. And uh, oh,
he kept dropping his fucking iPhone.
He had his shoes off and just the noises he was trying to make to try to pick it
up. It's like, why the fuck would you do to that? Do that to yourself,
these fucking people that treat their own bodies like a rental car,
I just don't understand it.
It's like you can't return this fucking thing at the end of the weekend.
You got to keep it.
This is the vessel that's going to bring you around for your fucking life.
You know? I mean, I should talk the way I fucking booze, but you know,
I still do my jumping jacks and I know a couple of cartwheels to keep the
stomach down, you know. So anyways, the flight fucking ends,
my travel is all fucked up for whatever reason. And I'm,
I'm basically, by the time they booked my hotel,
everything was sold out. So I had a hotel for the night,
but I couldn't check in until three in the afternoon. So I go, you know,
so they booked me in another hotel and the person, you know,
the travel person goes, so you got to check in at this hotel, you know,
at five 30 in the morning and then check out at 12 and then check in for the
other places. That is like at 3:00 PM it's like, is that cool?
And I'm like, no, it's not cool. Like, do you ever travel?
Is that the way you set up your travel? Do you want to switch hotels?
You know, in the same fucking city you staying. But I mean,
I don't have any choice, so it's going to have to be cool.
So I fucking take a cab over there.
I get to the place at like fucking five 30 in the morning. This is like planes,
trains and automobiles, right? I get there and they're like, ah,
what's an under? And I'm like, oh no. I'm like bill bird. They're like,
yeah, see I'm like William, Eh rumple fucking stills Gavin up.
Got It right. And the guy keeps going, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I'm like,
well I know it's not your fault.
So now it's like fucking five in the goddamn morning.
I've got no place to stay. And he goes,
well the bellhop can take you over to the fucking waffle house, right.
Sorry if I make Mike know he's here,
I got to move this laptop around cause I want you to fucking hear this thing.
It's like, yeah, I'm sorry if you know. Sorry about that.
So the fucking to now, I'd like fucking f five 20 in the morning.
I got no place to stay till three in the afternoon. I'm fucking dead tired.
I couldn't sleep because all fatty cakes over there was drinking the fucking a
jack and coke saw night's stepping over on me.
But this fucking piss and shit infested soak socks and now they don't have a
room for me and now I'm to a waffle house. Right.
So I get to the fucking waffle house,
you know it fucking quarter to six in the morning,
half expecting to see Jay z finishing the end of that song.
You know that fucking thing.
Go to the waffle house then we're going to do it again. How the fuck did you,
I guess he'd be walking out with them,
right the banger and then kick around at seven while Beyonce sings lemonade in
the background. I don't know what the fuck it is. Those two too. I,
I don't pretend to know. I'm an old man anyways, so I walk in there,
bunch of fucking characters and uh, I'm Blair, he died.
I'm not even fucking hungry,
but I know I can't just sit in there like some sort of vagrant soil or some eggs
in a fucking waffle.
And I'm sitting there and this black guy in there wearing a suit and he's,
he's like an anomaly. I don't know how to, he's a black guy,
but he isn't funny.
It's very rare. It's like an obese Asian.
It's very rare that you see like obesity, just, you know,
I don't know what food they eat over in Asia,
but I mean whatever that doing that,
doing it right with all the vegetables in the third fried, those,
those people are phenomenal.
Okay. And always getting hope, right? He wants you very rare.
You meet a black guy who wasn't funny and this fucking guy is not funny. Any,
won't shut the fuck up.
He keeps telling jokes and he's laughing at his own fucking jokes and I just
want to,
I want to stab myself with my fucking waffle house fucking fork.
So at one point he just won't shut up.
And then finally one of the waitresses makes a joke. Well,
the other way to see other way just goes, you know,
don't be walking up behind me. You know, you don't want to, you know,
you don't want to basically fuck with me. And then the lady goes,
and now she goes, I don't fight pregnant women. And she wasn't pregnant. Okay.
But admittedly it was a decent joke. The unfunny black dude in the suit,
you know, high pitch LAPP stands up, runs out of the waffle house,
goes out to the front and does like a fucking three 60 turn.
And I immediately, the fucking, you know,
the road weary comedian and me going like, all right, dude, it was funny.
It wasn't that fucking funny. And, uh,
okay.
He comes back in and then I don't, I mean, I didn't know what the fuck to do.
I'm like, what the fuck am I going to do with myself? I can't go to sleep.
My phone's running out of batteries. I'm charging it there.
It was just a fucking nightmare. So, uh, I just started calling hotels.
They're all fucking booked up. I don't know what's going on here in Nashville.
If there's some sort of fucking Banjo festival, I have no fucking idea,
but there's no way, some Jesus Shit, you know,
or some, you know, democratic or Republican convention, I have no fucking idea,
but I cannot get a room. So, you know, I'm like, what do I do?
So I called in the opion Jimmy show,
I talked to them for a minute and then I was just like, what am I doing?
So I finally called the cat and I just went over to the hotel then I was
supposed to be yet. And they were like, and they were like, oh yeah,
you know, somebody called said you, you know,
fucking last night if we could get you in. Unfortunately we cannot, blah blah,
blah, blah, blah. So I at least checked my bags, you know,
I felt like a fucking homeless person when I was in the waffle house with the
unfunny black dude.
And I had my fucking bags on the inside of myself as I sat in the booth,
made for two fucking people. But it was sitting there by myself. Right.
So I get to the hotel,
I at least checked in my bags and they had a fucking like a couch in the lobby
of this place. They go, we're already cleaning a room at this point,
it's six 30 in the morning. And I'm like, great. Whenever you can get me in,
if I gotta pay extra, I just don't give a shit. Right. So they say fine.
So I go over and I just laid down on the couch,
put my hat over my eyes and I just pass out.
I'm talking like I wasn't even trying to be a gentleman.
I had both feet up on the fucking couch. I was like,
this is my bed and I'm just sleeping there and I just keep hearing people's,
they're getting waking up, getting on with their day. Like,
do you want to get some small things?
I hear they have such great eggs and all this shit.
And then the one point this guy walked by, you know,
it was fucking assholes who whistle a fucking, you know, I think I tweeted,
nobody likes a whistler at some point. This fucking guy just came by whistling,
you know, just, it's just some random song. It's not even,
it's not even a fucking song.
He's just whistling cause that's what the fuck he does. Um,
and uh, then I just completely,
I was just zonked out and then all of a sudden I just feel somebody pushing me
once twice and I fucking wake up and then they go, hey Mr [inaudible],
your room's ready. I'm like thinking, oh thank God.
And I thought it was like seven 30 in the morning. I looked, it was like 10,
15 if it's sleeping there, like a bum full, like four hours.
So I finally ended up getting my fucking room.
And uh, fortunately it was one of these rooms that has the great curtains.
I was able to close them and it felt like midnight and I'm then I just fucking
crashed, woke up,
met some friends that I've met along the way on the road and uh,
took a drum lesson. Um,
I hate dropping names on this, but like,
they're one of my favorite bands out there right now.
Mute math is based out of here. And uh,
I got some lunch and Darren King actually gave me a little drum lesson.
I still stink, but it was fucking like,
I was beyond geeking out that I got to do it. So, um,
it was a bad day and I actually, uh,
ended up turning it around and uh,
I'll tell you what's funny is if you notice in the story, I never flipped up.
Bear with me, watch your ears. I gotta Click and drag this thing over.
Just hang on a second. I apologize. Here we go. Here we go.
It's almost over and it's over. And I just realized,
I have no idea how much time I'm doing here. The fuck does this mean here?
Four 47 448 448 one millimeters is just a metric system.
Where the fuck's the timer? How do I tell him at the time I'm doing all right.
You're just going to have to fucking deal with this. I apologize. Anyways. Um,
I've got this weird thing when like major shit happens. Like I don't, um,
I don't flip out like bigger shit like this.
I don't flip out little shit bugs me.
Like 20 minutes ago I'm going down in the elevator and we just hit every fucking
floor and every fucking floor is another person coming on a fucking full grown
adult wearing their name, a name tag around their neck.
Like it's their first day of preschool and everybody knows everybody. Hey Carl.
Like the shorts, you wear those to the meeting.
It crazy right down one more floor. Every fucking floor.
It's getting more and more packed and then I have to sit there and listen to
office humor. Right? I'll tell you right now, if you think every once in awhile,
a random black dude in a suit in a waffle house isn't funny.
Wait till you're in a crowded elevator with a bunch of people that sit in
cubicles all day.
They had their fucking name tags around their neck listening to their jokes for
eight fucking floors that I like. I was, by the time I got to the third floor,
I was fucking livid.
I was so fucking angry that the people around me could sense it,
that when I went to get off the elevator, even women got out of the way.
So I'm not proud of that.
But you would think I would have flipped out at the big dude stepping over me,
or I would have thought this anyways,
or I would've flipped out when my room wasn't ready. I would've flipped out.
You know? Even when I sent the text message to my travel person,
I didn't curse. I didn't say that they fucked it up.
I know somebody fucked it up.
But I've learned in the past to not just slice the head off of the first person.
I just went very like, you know, I don't know what happened,
but this is not acceptable. People knew I was coming here for two months.
I don't understand. I've never had this problem before. This can't happen again.
I am now on my way to a waffle house at five 21 in the morning with all of my
bags. And I just, you know what, what else do you need? The fucking Sake, right?
So anyways, it all ended up working out and uh,
I got some great food out here and uh,
I ended up running into one of the, uh, cast members of Nashville,
which is my wife's favorite fucking show, unfortunately,
just got canceled and I ran into the Guy Charles Estin,
and he was the coolest fucking guy. And I was like, oh my God,
my wife loves you. Show is there any way I could get a picture? And he goes, no,
put it on video. He goes, watch this. He goes, you do the intro.
He was so fucking cool. So I just was like, hey, yeah, woo. I'm in Nashville.
I ran into one of the locals and then it turns into it's his face and he just
goes, hey, thanks for watching the show.
She freaked out and I got some good points.
So thank you to Charles for making my fucking a make it my married life a little
easier. So, uh, so there you go. I don't know how much time that took up.
According to a Garageband, I'm at 540 something.
540 fucking of these.
Okay.
Oh, they count in the little things. Was it 540 seconds?
My really supposed to do that math. Had I not done 10 minutes yet.
600 seconds is 10 minutes. Oh Jesus.
I don't even know what I'm talking about at this point. Sorry,
I've got to click on this thing here. It's not letting me do it. All right,
here we go. A little, a little advertising here. Alright, ZipRecruiter,
everybody.
Okay.
Are you hiring? Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and now you can.
Next, please mention the talking points below. Well, why would I,
you wrote them. I'm going to read them. Okay.
With ziprecruiter.com you can post your job to 100 plus job sites including
social media network networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface, no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by over 800,000 businesses and
right now list my uh, my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/berm that's ziprecruiter.com/burr hey
ziprecruiter.com/burn all right track or smack cash,
Mac phone, smart homes. Technology has made everything like wicked's Matt Do.
But losing your stuff still makes smart people feel really stupid.
These wicked stupid tracker makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size to voice device that locates
misplaced keys, wallets, bags, computers, anything in seconds.
Just pair tracker to your smart phone,
attach it to anything and find its precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Lose your phone,
press the button on track and your phone rings
on its own. Silence. Silence, silent.
Sorry with got 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest crowd gps network in
the world, so your last item shows up on a map. Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything. Again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the spelled t,
h e t r a C K e r.com the tracker.com enter the Promo code bar.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to find is their website. Go to tracker,
the tracker.com right now and enter your Promo code burn for
for 30% off your entire order. Again, hey, that's the tracker,
bee tracker.com Promo Code Bar and lastly, but hopefully not okay.
Lastly, but not least. Alright. Boyle and branch. Oh, sorry.
Ball and branch. Well, I don't know what the feel l,L and branch.
All right. As you set out to improve yourself.
There is one simple thing you can do every day to help you be in your best to be
your best in every situation that's getting a good night's sleep,
but Jesus Christ, Lord knows I never do that.
Ball and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in there,
super comfortable luxury linens and they do it right.
Did the first bedding company to be fair trade certified,
which means that your sheets come from the work of happy hands, not crying.
Children in sweatshops in beautiful packaging made entirely from recycled and
sustainable materials. You can only get their sheets in one place.
That's bowl and brand.com where you know you're paying for quality and not
department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go to ball,
that's B o l l and branch.com and they'll let you let you try them risk-free for
30 days. If you don't love them, you can send them back.
You have nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to ball and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets, towels,
blankets, do.
VA covers everything plus free shipping and all their products come beautifully
packaged in their signature boxes.
Go to ball and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order and use Promo Code
Burr ball in branch.com Promo Code Burn. And mercifully, that's the end.
Hey,
I've got to ask you guys a question here and I apologize for all the extraneous
fucking noise, if that's the right word here.
Um,
I went into the, uh, the drug store out here,
cause I forgot my Aleve to count to help my inflamed Sciatica here.
And um, sciatic nerve I should say. And um,
I went in there and this, this campaign,
that red nose fucking fun thing, whatever. And it's all these,
it's some sort of charity and it's all these fucking people.
Famous people wearing the red nose. So I'm going, what the, what is this?
I keep seeing this.
So I start reading the box and it says Walgreens will donate 100% of everything
that they gain, collect or whatever.
To this red nose camp, red nose fund.
100% is going to this red nose fund.
So I'm like, all right, what is it? What is the fund?
Nowhere on the box will it say what the fuck it is.
It doesn't say what it's raising money for. Nowhere on the box.
So I asked the lady behind the counter and I go, so what is this for?
If I buy one of these red noses, what is this for? She goes, Oh,
you one of these,
and it was like a little fucking gift certificate off of fucking chapstick or
something. I go, no, no, no, no. I don't like what I get. If I buy a red nose,
like where does the money go? Who am I helping out? She goes, oh, I don't know.
It's like my first day, and I just laughed. I was like, well,
I'm going to just start the fucking green hat fund and everything's going to go
to me. And she sorta like, I guess half ass laughed.
I should have told it to the black guy in the suit and the fucking waffle house,
he would've ran out of the place then 15 cartwheels and come back in though.
That's not that funny. Um, I'm telling you man, that's the new,
I'm not saying the red nose thing is a scam, but it's pretty fucking shifty,
pretty shady.
Then I'm sitting and looking at all these celebrities and it's just the red nose
fund and there's nothing on there. Same way the money goes,
you know, isn't it,
shouldn't that red nose thing bring up a couple of red flags there?
I think that that's the new,
there's two new things going on in this country that are actually generating
income for people.
The legal selling of weed at the state level and um,
nonprofits.
Nonprofit is like the new hardware store.
Like back in the day you had to open a store and actually sell shit.
And nowadays you can just start fucking come up with a mirror,
a mirror. Now a ribbon, a fucking wristband,
a red fucking nose, have people dump ice water over their fucking head,
whatever it is. You know, some of them are legit.
I got this feeling, most of them aren't. And I kind of feel like
if you're old like me,
and you remember the late eighties when all those televangelists were on TV and
they went to like this national fucking level and they just made hundreds of
millions of dollars before it all just came out that it was just this giant
fucking cash grab. I feel like all those fucking nonprofits,
it has to be going in that direction and how all these sports, uh,
sports leagues get in bed with all of these fucking people. Um,
I dunno, maybe they have enough money,
maybe they have enough money to keep it silent. But uh, I don't know.
I'm kind of done. I give money to saint Jude's hospital. That's it.
Everything else, I just,
I don't have the fucking time to figure out whether or not you're a fucking scam
or not because I gave to that wounded warrior shit. I gave so many,
I gave so much fucking money.
I used to donate like 10% of the Shit I made in the advertising to those fucking
people. And then people started sending me these,
these articles and the next thing you know they get investigated and all that
type of shit and I don't even, I didn't,
I just stopped following the story and I just stopped giving them money cause
I don't know, I don't know. I don't know if it's true or not.
I don't even fucking want to know.
But like I just feel like the future of helping people out is literally walking
up to a wounded warrior. Like finding out where the fuck they live and be like,
what do you need? Go out and get it.
Or you raised the money and then you give it to them. But then if I raise it,
then do I become one of those people and be like,
oh we have a little bit of overhead and all of a sudden I have some sick ass
drum room and I just bring a fucking box of bandaids to a fucking veteran.
I mean that's what seems like all these, I don't know. I'm,
I'm a cynical son of a bitch, but my new shit is I want to just, I'm,
I still love doing charities. I love doing benefits.
I did one the other night for like a fucking, it was for like a private school.
It's like, it's a fucking private school. Like you guys don't need money.
It's like, oh, it's for the people who can't afford it. It's like, is it,
who knows what it is? You just saying what it is and then what?
Then all of a sudden they, yeah. Who gets the money? Where does it go?
Where does that person go? Are they in Tahiti? Are they helping somebody out?
Nobody fucking knows. It's brilliant. It's fucking brilliant. Um,
I hope that red nose things is on the label is on the labels on the level.
Sorry, I didn't get a good night's sleep. You know,
those hotel couches and what they fucking used to be there.
Um,
I honestly have no idea how much time I've done here.
I'm up to like 838 of these seconds here.
I'm just going to say this seconds,
right.
Well, let's see if there's 600 seconds in 10 minutes.
So that means there'd be 1800 seconds and a half. There's no fucking way.
That's only a second. What if it's two seconds?
I've gotta be coming up. I'm going to say it's two seconds. Fuck it.
It's two seconds.
So all I got to do is just make it up to 900 and I got another 49 to go. Oh,
it's fucking easy. Let's talk a little playoff hockey. Everybody.
Anybody watch a, I keep missing just to how busy I am. I keep missing, um,
that uh, that Tampa Bay Pittsburgh series, I caught the end of uh,
uh,
game three with the penguins were up and then they gave him a couple of right
there threads to put it out of reach.
And I fucking sent a buddy of mine in Pittsburgh,
a text congratulating them because as much as I don't like what the penguins
cheap shot artists have done to the Bruins, uh, you know,
I don't take it to the level that I don't want my friend's teams to win.
So I said congratulations. And the second I sent it,
Tampa Bay scored one and I felt like I jinxed up for half a second. But um,
I've been watching the blues and uh,
in San Jose shacks and a,
this is fucking huge tonight for the blues because San Jose obviously adjusted
to whatever the fuck the blues were doing in game one. And uh,
so now blues have to adjust to whatever San Jose was doing because San Jose
Pretty uh,
dominated pretty much wire to wire the last game.
And uh, I dunno, it's making me nervous as a,
as a bandwagon blues fan, they obviously got to win this.
That's such a stupid thing to say. It was a, it's just one, a big one. Bill.
Should they not go down three games to one? You fucking dope.
A big shout out to all the soccer fans over there in Europe that got so fucking
annoyed at everything that I said that I shouldn't talk about. Uh,
um, sports over in Europe, uh,
you guys all make a great point cause I don't watch them and I don't know
anything about them. But, uh,
what you failed to understand is how much I enjoy irritating the shit out of
people that I'd never met before. So I stand by. What the fuck?
I said you guys should have some sort of in the premier league,
you should have a fucking play off play off the fact that somebody can win a
fucking championship because another team came to like a tie and like that's it.
Just imagine
every fucking movie about soccer is always this the big fucking game.
Right? And then somebody comes down and scores a goal.
It's not like the stars of the movie standing around waiting for somebody to
fucking,
okay,
you know, we'll have a one one tie with somebody.
Is this sitting there and fucking street clothes or sitting in an apartment?
Okay.
Doing Jello shots with each other. I don't know. I'm just fucking with you.
I know.
Remember that's the best of Solo movie victory ended them with them walking away
from the game. Oh No, no. They were going to do it.
They wanted to escape and then they came back because they wanted to beat the
guys. And if that was actually based on anything real,
yeah.
Um, the game would have ended and then they would've won.
They would have been brought back to the prison camp and they would've been
beaten to death.
But instead what ended up happening was they came back and they,
they beat the Nazis, these prisoners allied prisoners of war,
and then they fucking, uh,
they just walked out with the crowd that stormed onto the field and gave them
extra clothes and shit.
MMM [inaudible]
I dunno, I'm sure it was based on a true story, but, uh,
I've seen enough of the Germans and their respect for life outside of their own
country. Okay. For people who are non German,
I think that they would have just opened up on the crowd.
Yeah.
So I'm calling bullshit. That movie was called victory, by the way, by the way.
It was a great, it was actually really enjoy that movie,
but it was when I first got cable, so who knows.
Um,
anyways, is that, is that a half hour?
I'm up to 962 seconds or a 1800?
I have no fucking idea. Yeah.
You know what
I'm going to find out here because I'm going to have to do the Monday morning
podcast like this one also. And uh,
my timing will be a little bit better on the next one cause I'll know exactly
how much time I'm doing. I just don't understand why this would fucking thing.
Wouldn't tell me how much time, but I'm not gonna start hitting buttons going.
It's gonna be irritating to you if you listen to it on a fucking with
headphones.
So anyways, that's it for the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Just checking in on your hope. You can see,
have a great weekend and here's a little bit of music and uh,
enjoy the a clips from a podcasts from years gone by.
And of course like walking can air where there it is.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
hey, what's going on? It's bill bar.
It's the Monday morning podcast and uh, April, gloomy,
rainy,
depressing Monday morning here in Los Angeles.
Um, probably days or rest or depressing out here because, uh,
it's usually sunny and it's what you expect out here.
I feel like I'm going to go into a Karen Carpenter song, rainy David Monday.
[inaudible] yeah. [inaudible] really?
Is that a reason to stop eating? I don't think it is. Wow.
Wow. I just started off real mean did night well. Well Shit.
Well who gives a fuck? It's a gloomy Monday and a I attacked a dead anorexic.
How do you like that? That's how I start the Monday morning podcast.
So there you go. If you're new to my page, um, I do one of these, um,
every Monday morning, cause I say Monday, oh, did I say run day?
Every Monday morning I do a podcast and I evidently I attack some,
uh, defenseless dead person. That's how I started off.
Only if it's overcast. If it was sunny, it would have,
I would have a completely different side. But basically,
I do want to say these every Monday and I answer questions that some of my 14
listeners send in. Um, lately I've been giving out advice.
People's been asking me advice and sometimes I ask questions and uh,
hopefully in the end of it, uh, nobody learns anything. And you know,
you've wasted 15 minutes of your life. That's what I'm trying to do.
And speaking of wasting 15 minutes of your life,
I am actually sitting in my apartment, my little villa,
and uh, really made me sound like at a pool. Boy, it didn't. Um,
my little villa here and I'm waiting for a plumber and uh,
you know, I don't want to judge the guy because I never met him,
but this motherfucker sky was supposed to be here at nine o'clock in the goddamn
morning. All right? It's two minutes test the hour of 10 o'clock.
Now I don't know what time zone you live in, what world you're in,
but in my little neck of the woods, 10 oh two, now it's 10 oh three.
It just turned on my cable box. It's fucking 10 oh three 10.
Oh three is not nine o'clock. And goddammit, I want some answers.
I'm grabbing to ball my hand up into a fist and fucking pounded on my coffee
table like a, like some,
like that guy in the Spiderman comic books. Who's,
who's the guy at the daily planet? Jamison. Huh?
With his fucking a, it's such a weird way of going gray. Didn't he?
Just the side of his head turned white all the way around and then on top it was
jet black and he'd always be chomping on a fucking cigar. You know, just,
I don't want to tax Stan Lee, but you know, it's really, you know, I got it.
He's the boss. All right. What am I doing? Okay. All right, let's,
let's fucking get back to this. Let's get down to brass tacks here. Okay.
Why am I waiting for a plumber?
I'll tell you why I'm looking for a plumber because for some reason my sink,
when the water comes out lately,
it smells like swamp ass.
Um, I don't know what it is.
There's definitely a funk coming out of my sink and it's not coming out of the
kitchen sink. So I've ruled out some sort of outside sources,
obviously, you know, cause it was coming from the street,
the main water waterline. I think every, it'd be fucking everything.
It'd be coming out of everything right now.
Do I have any plumber listeners out there? You know, can you help me out?
Because evidently this fuck is not showing up.
It's 10 oh four and he's still not here. See,
this is why the United States of America is starting to lag behind China and all
of them I've had in China, when you call a plumber,
48 of them show up at fucking eight 58 begging you. Then they have a wrench.
You know what I mean?
Somebody just fucking bites down the pipe and three other guys just start
spinning the guy around, you know, but not in America.
I got to wait for this motherfucker to show up. I'll tell you what sucks too,
is I don't know if they act stupid, but it just,
that that makes it hurt even more
is when you can't figure out how to fix the sink.
And then some guy comes up memorial boom pole, you know,
with his fucking ass hanging out, he knows how to fix it.
That's why I've started to become handy. Okay.
Because I actually sat down and I analyzed that the other day and you know,
fixing a sink is not a gift. You know what I'm saying?
It's a skill. It's something you learned inventing the sink. Okay.
Or the toilet like that. That guy, uh,
Eddie crapper or whatever his fucking name was. I know his,
his last name was crapper. Okay. And because of him,
we don't have to shit outside.
And what's what banks does he get his last name becomes slang for taking a dump.
Tell me he didn't die. A bitter rich man. Jesus Christ. You know,
some people man, it's just these, you know, they, they,
they do such good and what do they get out of it? Huh?
Jesus Christ. I mean, I bet you,
and your last name was crapper that every female in that family could not wait
to get married and just get away from that Goddamn last name. I mean,
they probably took the first thing that came down the pike.
That'd be a great thing to Google and go check out the amount of women with the
last name crapper that married the first trucker that fucking fingered him on a
fucking Tuesday night. Jesus Christ.
Just because they were shameful of them.
Their maiden name was probably led to some sort of child abuse and alcoholism.
And that's probably another reason why it's 10 oh six in the fucking plumber
still living here. I really hope he shows up halfway through this. Okay.
Cause you guys have watched me give this guy a piece of my fucking mind and I
won't curse either. So we can't leave. What is he doing? What could be what's,
what's he doing? Huh? He driving and you know he's got a van.
Do you know if you're a carpenter, you gotta pick up if you're,
if you're a plumber, you got a van. You know,
because in case it rains you can't have it go on the pipes and they get all
rusted. I don't know why. What is he doing? Tenancy at the army, navy store,
buying some more Dickies. You know that what they do is,
what do they trade their underwear for? Their Dickies.
So their fucking crack of their ass is hanging out 10 oh seven okay.
Anyways, yeah. So that's the deal. I started,
I started to learn how to fix shit. Okay,
I'll fix the leaky faucet the other day, which is unbelievably easy,
but it makes no goddamn sense.
You fucking take the handle off and there's this,
this little rubber stopper with this spring in there and that's all it is.
You take it out and stick the mother fucker back.
You stick a new one in there and magically it stops leaking. I don't get it.
It's not like it's in the pipe. I have no idea why it works,
but it works.
And I went on the Internet within three seconds I learned how to do it. Okay.
My ass wasn't hanging out of the back of my pants and I didn't charge somebody
fucking $200 and I was on time.
Damn motherfucker. Okay. So anyways,
I do one of these things every single week and people ask me questions and I
hide upcoming gigs.
Like the fact that I'm going to be at a, this week,
I'm going to be at as Amy's in Chicago and uh,
it's actually downtown Chicago on the 14th and 15th.
On the 16th I'll be in,
in the Saint Charles and on the 17th I'll be in Vernon hills, Illinois.
And I got to tell you something I really, really enjoy doing, uh,
this Gig at especially the downtown Chicago. So this nice small,
and I mean it looks like a walk in closet. The place is so small and uh,
I dunno man,
it's like an old school comedy club and all these old comedy photos,
they just left them up to like to take a fucking museum.
I love the place and I always have great shows there. So,
and I'm going to the cubs game on the 15th Bay, be like my third,
fourth time going to Wrigley field, you know.
And here I am pitching about a plumber.
I really ought to count my blessings here.
Go into a fucking cubs game this week. Okay. And continuing on on the 29th,
May 29th through June 1st I'm making my triumphant return to a New York City,
Caroline's comedy club. Uh,
I got a whole brand new hour last time I was out there. I taped my, uh,
my one hour comedy special,
which I have information about that I will be giving out later on in this
podcast. Huh? Look at me. Look at me. Teasing it a little bit.
Making you stick around. Huh? Don't roll your eyes at me. I know what I'm doing.
I'm playing the fucking game. Uh,
let's see and what else we got here and then you go into June
and I actually forgot about this date. I thought I had a couple,
a couple of weeks off after Caroline's, but evidently not.
I'm going right back out to Raleigh, North Carolina.
Good nights comedy club. How the fuck did I have a date there, man?
I'm turning 40 on the 10th. I planned on coming home on the second,
getting into the fetal position, doing some crunches
and not eating any carbs until June 10th when I turned 40 goddamn years old.
But now I have to fly across this country and go to Raleigh, North Carolina.
The desolate, the frightening Raleigh, North Carolina.
The what the fuck happened to the downtown area that you know,
it's a beautiful part of the, the this, the of the state during the day.
Raleigh, North Carolina downtown. I'm not talking about NC state, NC state,
that that place is nice.
I actually went there for two semesters in 87 88 and if you want to know while
we went there for two semesters, go online and Google Bill Burns,
fucking NC state a fucking transcript and you'll figure out why I left after
that. But the downtown area, that's one of those downtowns where, you know,
you could tell at some point in the past, the history, it was, it was a place,
it was hopping, it was jumping. They'll make a narrow moonshine down there.
Right. And then they know what happened. You know what? I bet the wall,
the dreaded Walmart. That's what happened. They built a Walmart, then they,
then they made a mall, the Crabtree mall.
Is that what you guys go in the whole downtown area? Just,
it's a fucking ghost town.
Past six oh one in the evening and I'm just left down there by myself,
downtown in the fucking hotel. I hate it. I need people around me.
I'm a city person. God Damn. People all fucking leave. And then I'm down there.
I got to go out and hail the cab and all that stuff is just homeless people.
It's like that fucking, what does that movie? 28 days.
That's what I feel like I'm in. I'm still going to a Zombie movie.
So if you're working downtown Raleigh and you're going to go to one of my shows,
why don't you hang out at work?
Just hang out at work and go straight to the clubs.
When I walk out to get a cab,
I can actually see another fucking human being that looks like they don't have
hepatitis. All right.
And the next Gig I had coming up this June 19th to the 21st I'm going to be at
the punchline in Atlanta. Uh,
that's another one of my favorite comedy clubs.
I bet that Janie's Caroline's good nights punchline Atlanta.
I like all of those clubs. I like all of them. They're just good clubs, good,
clean fun. And I'm going to come in there with my potty mouth,
June 19th to the 21st and uh,
I don't know, I've been to Atlanta a lot lately,
so I'm hoping that I'm going to start to build a following out there.
I always seem to get a good turnout and I got a whole nother new hour for you.
You sons of bitches. And
then after that you guys, you're on your own. Just go to my website.
You can click on it right there. If you're looking at my mind space page,
I manage.
I imagine most of you are secretly listening to this in your cubicle and you've
probably reduced the window. Is that what you did?
And now you sit there and looking at what are you look at in a cubicle? Huh?
What are you looking at? Spreadsheet. Some sort of counting thing with,
with assets and liabilities and you're rubbing your chin as if you're not
listening to me. Huh? Well that's good. You know what?
I think that's a good thing. You know,
you should do today's take a magnet run right down the back of your bosses
hardware, not as hardware, his fucking hard drive. That's what you do.
And if he walks into the office right in the middle of you doing that,
what you do is you smile. They've opened smile,
which causes his defenses to go down.
And then you fling that magnet at him like a fucking Chinese star and you hit
him right in the forehead. Now the great thing about knocking somebody out is,
um, as far as I know, as far as my experience with getting knocked out,
is you forget the previous three minutes.
So as long as you fire that fucking magnet at him before the three minutes are
up, he won't even remember what happened. But the key is,
is to do it in a manner before he can be like, you know,
yell your name and say, what are you doing in this office? You know,
Jennifer fucking, whatever.
I'm so bad at coming up with fucking
God damn it. Jennifer will go with Sullivan that there's a,
there's a fucking basic name. That's why I can't write scripts.
The stories are always good. But my fucking name, you know the hero's name,
Joe Smith. William the worst. Um, so I can never commit.
Client never could come up with a good alias.
What's your name? Bob. Bob.
What Avenue? All right, Robert,
why don't you get in the back of the fucking car? Man, I didn't do anything.
All right, let's get on to the a have I ever been arrested? Yes.
Yes I have. Yes, I have. I innocent arrested, drinking and driving
back into December of 1989 and if you'd like to hear more of the story,
tune in next week. Um, I'll wait a minute. What did I say? Oh, I know.
That's right. I'm going to tell you guys my DVD is coming out. Um,
but first we're going to answer some of the, uh,
some of the questions that people have asked me. Um,
here's a question I might've answered it before. OK. Podcast,
question number one. A, this is how many,
I have actually went into some old emails and I found that a bunch of other ones
so that I didn't get to. So who knows. Here we go. Question one. Hey Bill,
have you ever thought about going to Iraq to entertain the military?
I served in the Gulf War and we liked having entertainers. Come see us.
If you have a few have already gone. What was it like for you?
You would fucking kill? Um, no I have not.
I have not gone over there for the simple, you know,
the only way I would go over there is if I went through six weeks of boot camp
first like you did. And uh, you know, they gave,
they taught me how to fucking kill somebody. You know what I'm saying?
That's like not knowing how to swim and then doing a fucking, you know,
entertain some people on a tugboat during, during choppy water.
You know what I mean? That, that, to be honest with you,
I would love to go to Iraq, but I'd love to go over there.
And when it was fucking peaceful.
And I experienced the culture over there when there are no insurgence and a,
yeah, that's the thing. You know what I mean?
I know they fly into the fucking base and I'm surrounded by a bunch of marines
and that type of shit. But you know, I've just watched too many wills,
Smith movies where he's the only guy left and I don't know how to fire a gun.
So, uh, you know, I don't have that kind of balls like Bob hope would go,
you know, he went all over Vietnam with like a fucking golf bag and an umbrella.
I guess he never died. Right. Maybe that should be a, you know, but you know,
chaos theory, I don't think he'd get killed on the base, but you know,
I'd be one of those guys. Yeah. Fucking, you know,
the plane I was in would get shot and suddenly everyone in the plane would
survive. But I'd fall out the bottom through the Goddamn book.
I'll entertain the troops. Okay. I've done it a bunch of times,
but I've done it over here. I, I don't, I don't do away games.
I'm like Roger Climates when he played for the Astros. Okay. I'm on steroids.
I'm cheating on my wife and I don't fucking pitch and I wreck.
I'll be honest with you, I'm terrified to go over there. There you go. Okay.
That's why you're a fucking marine and I'm a civilian and I respect you and uh,
you know, I'll fucking, uh, you can listen to these podcasts in Iraq,
you know what I mean? What am I, what am I fucking Chuck Norris,
me getting all defensive because I don't have the balls to go. Oh yeah.
That's basically it. Yeah.
I don't want to go over there and then somehow get kidnapped and ended up being,
you know, rocking back and forth gently and an orange jumpsuit is there,
you know,
they're reading shit about our lot and then they saw my fucking head off and I'm
really sitting there going like, you know what, why did I come over here?
Um, okay, moving on. Question number one. That was one a.
Okay. Uh,
did you do a voice on grand theft auto for there was a biker dude that sounds
just like you. If it wasn't you, you got to check it out. Actually yes I did.
I did do a,
a voiceover on that and it was a big thrill to do that and I got to give a big
thanks to uh,
to Laszlo for hooking me up and uh,
Jimmy Norton full hooking me up with the opiod Anthony show cause that's how I
met Laszlo. And then I got in there to do the boys know. Boom.
Um, so yeah, that works. Uh, question number two,
I noticed you have strike force MMA and your top friends.
I was wondering who are a couple of your favorite MMA fighters? Um,
that's just a friend I accepted and then I guess they switched their picture.
Mixed martial arts. Um, I dunno, I do watch the, I watch,
uh, what do I watch? I watch the UFC fights. I watch,
uh, I watched their reality show, which of course,
I can't remember the name of the ultimate fighter, this,
this season where they have to fight their way just to get into the house.
And uh, what the fuck's his name there? The Junkyard Dog.
I'm getting them fucking confused with old time wrestlers.
Who's the guy who knocked out? Chuck Lidell,
the fucking guy who goes out and kicks the shit out of you.
Where's the chain and Shit, you know, beats the fuck out of people.
Randy Jackson. Yeah. And then the other guy with the fucking,
you don't want to fuck with me. Cauliflower ears. You know,
I actually have a theory that if you just said,
you don't even need to get the black belt. If you just have some,
somebody box your ears and you get those cauliflower ears,
no one's gonna fuck with you in a bar because they just look at those fucked up
ears, those exploded vegetable ears and they're just like,
that guy could fucking snap my neck,
choke me out and give me the superman punch with the flying knee all at the same
fucking time. Did I even answer the question? Who are some of my favorite ones?
Uh, I'd like to match Sarah. I love the shit he talked about. Uh,
what's his face was Saint Pierre. That's the kind of shape I would like to be in
for my 40th birthday. That evidentaly I'll be contemplating in downtown Raleigh,
North Carolina. Alright. You know what, this podcast is starting to seem long,
so let me, let me blow through these next fucking questions. All right.
Number three, Bill,
did you hook up with any of the stewardesses at the airport from last week's
podcast? Oh yeah. I hooked up with all three of them and they,
we had a fucking force them right out in the open, you know,
and that didn't violate any new fucking Patriot Act. Now I didn't.
And uh, thanks for bringing that up. Okay. I Dunno,
I was gonna go up and say what's up to him.
But there was something about their blue pantyhose that just,
I really found it intimidating. Question number four. I was wondering,
since you're such a big, such a bug sports fan, a big sports fan,
what is your best sports memory from your childhood?
Um, whoa. Fuck that. Let's go with something funnier then. Uh, how about, uh,
here's my best, uh, my best thought. Okay.
Here's a good sports memory. When the, uh,
when the New England Patriots beat the Los Angeles Raiders,
um, what was it, 1985. The year we get,
we get destroyed in the super bowl. We were a wild card and uh,
that's what we beat the jets. And then the next week we'd beat,
look at me with the memory, beat the jets,
and then we'd beat the Raiders and I went down to the,
the airport in Providence, Rhode Island.
And it was like me and like only 70 other people at this point, you know.
And we met at all the players as they got off the plane,
all the old school guys, Julius Adams,
I remember somebody reaching over and slamming him really hard on his shoulder,
like hitting them way too hard. And he fucking looked at me like I did it.
And I was like, oh, it wasn't me. It was the guy behind me. But, uh,
that was the first time I saw a bunch of athletes up close. Uh,
Tony Easten completely expressionless.
I remember he was wearing a butterscotch members only jacket, I swear to God.
Um,
and he looked like he was on his way to home depot and right down I should've
known that he was going to get crushed in the Superbowl. But, um,
I would say that, you know what, Bruins Games,
the first Bruins games and went to the Boston Garden.
They used to always go to Bruins.
Canadians actually went to that bench clearing brawl. If you go on a youtube,
it's the one where Chris Niland, uh,
I was at the game where he hit Rick Middleton in the teeth with the stick.
And then as he was walking off, that's why he walked off the ice.
And then he pushed a 10 lensman who chased them down. And next thing you know,
it was a bench clearing brawl.
And Terry O'Reilly and his suit was grabbing onto somebody and never in water.
Quad. I was good time. All right. I'm just babbling here.
I'll just wait for my plumber. 10 23 motherfuckers still not here.
Okay. Uh, wow. I'm getting bored with myself here. Number five.
Uh, what do you think of the comedy genre? Anti humor.
Like the type by Neil Hamburger and ted. I don't know those guys.
I watched them and they seemed funny to me. You know, I dunno.
It's not anti humor is it? I don't know who gives a fuck. Alright,
so I was watching one of these and who was throwing food at you?
I already answered that. That's a donut. It's a donut hole.
If you see the video on my page, it was a group of people. They were, uh,
advertisers. They all worked at the same place.
I started trashing them and they threw a doughnut hole at me and evidently I
didn't give a fuck. Um, number seven,
when you have these horrible thoughts about people,
are you able to keep your face, stoic, mind, wrinkles up?
And I don't notice until the person looks at me. If so, how do you play it off?
Um, no, I'm usually cursing like what I think is under my breath,
but out loud and then they look right at me.
I literally walked through like an airport,
go and look at this fucking guy with fuck kind of shirt is that,
and I think I'm kind of doing it in my head or whispering,
but I'm saying it loud enough that they look right at me and then I look away,
which is pretty pathetic. Okay. Which is,
you know what this podcast is getting to static. It's way too long.
Let's get the thing. Okay. My DVD don't sell dog.
The big announcement is going to be coming out in September of 2008 and the my
DVD,
my a one hour special will also be shown on comedy central in September of 2008.
So I have all summer to write some, uh, to write some new jokes,
which I already have already got a whole new hour. So, uh, all right.
This podcast, I mean minutes, just this. Yeah,
this podcast is really fucking long and I didn't even get to half the shit I
want to talk about.
I want to tell you guys how I was back to drink and Budweiser.
I've come full circle. Actually.
I started off with Michelob light then and quickly went to Budweiser and then
throughout the years I switched to vodka.
Then I ended up with fucking Johnny Walker Black and now I'm right back to
Budweiser again. And uh,
I guess that was the moment after Johnny Walker Black where I was supposed to
admit that I had a problem and stopped cold.
But evidently I'm going to run the cycle all over again and go back and start
dating some of the same psychos that I dated, you know,
next week.
I'll tell you the story about me getting arrested for drinking and driving back
and fucking June, no,
December of 1989 I was on my way back from Boston college to go watch the
Patriots play fucking the Los Angeles rams cause I got season tickets.
Who knew they were going to be five and 11? Um, anyways, so that's the posture.
You know what? It started off fucking, it started off strong.
I was trashing the art of plumbing and then at dead Karen Carpenter,
and then it just sort of tapered off. I, you know, I don't want to happen.
I shut up, fucking quit while I was ahead. But anyways,
thanks to everyone who listens to these podcasts, I really appreciate it. And a,
if you would actually, you know something, if you enjoy my podcast,
could you please let people know about him because, uh, you know,
I burn up a lot of minutes every week on my fucking cell phone.
I'm getting brain cancer and I'm talking to like 15 people. And um,
I'd like to break 20.
If I could get it up to 20 people before June 10th when I turned 40,
that would make me feel a whole lot better. All right? So, uh,
thanks to everybody who, uh, who has been listening and,
uh, sorry, all the Karen Carpenter fans, I'm sorry to people who are plumbers.
Actually, you know what? I'm not sorry. Okay. I'm not fucking sorry,
because one of your,
I'll be sorry when some of you guys from the plumber's union have a little
talking to, it's 10 20 fucking seven
I started this podcast at 10 Oh three so did the 24 minute podcast.
I was hoping that the guy was going to walk in during the middle of it.
We could have a little reality show moment what he did,
and you know what probably happened?
He probably walked up half way through the stairs and hurt me pitching about
fucking plumbers on my podcast. He didn't hear me talking to anybody.
So you thought it was crazy or I was berating my wife,
my non-existent wife. Oh God. Look at a gloom.
Look at the fucking gloom out the window. All right, that's it.
So please come out and see me,
a Chicago with Janie's this week or Caroline's in New York City at the end of
the month or at a good nights in Raleigh, North Carolina,
or the punchline in Atlanta, Georgia next month. All right, your motherfuckers.
I have a CD up on a iTunes called emotionally unavailable,
the expanded edition. Why don't you go there, buy it.
Buy for friend for plumber,
fucking break the CD and half stab him and his juggler.
He's late and that's it. That's the Monday morning podcast. The next week.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].